okay welcome to the last video of the d4
d5 complex which essentially means yeah
looking at the Queens gambit I want to
make a book recommendation on a book
which I really like about the subject
itself oops
to grab it yeah it's cop playing the
Queens gambit from from white from
whites point of view and it's by last
shunned off a Danish Grandmaster and
he's done a very nice job of presenting
the line some that a lot of lines that I
recommended here are in this book so for
instance what's what's in this book he's
showing the exchange variation in both
forms and this in this form and also
after this should be seven he goes
through the main line Slavs as well
let's go back he's actually recommending
to to allow this and he plays the the 95
variation does a nice job of presenting
the material there he's also covering
the complete but Vinick line and also
anti Moscow stuff and since very sharp
stuff but this is I think it's done a
nice job of presenting this material in
an accessible fashion it's it's not it's
not a really huge book and just have a
quick look it's 250 pages for the whole
Queens gambit so it's it's not
comparable in in in depth to the likes
of those books by Boris abrooke
withstand 2,000 at 1,200 pages of one d4
which is very nice but if you really try
to work with this kind of book it's
impossible to to remember all this so
it's not a nice shock of job of
compressing the material to in some way
that you can actually read this play
through the lines and understand most of
the stuff against the Queens gambit
accepted he's also recommending e4 so um
a lot of stuff I just recommended it's
in this book I'm not sure about what
what he's doing against achiever and
maybe it's actually the line I I
mentioned but I don't know this book by
heart but I think it's a nice starting
point if you want to play a nice active
repertoire against the Queen's Gambit
but what you need to keep in mind is of
course there are some tricky people who
like to play the Queen's Gambit is black
but actually don't play 1 d5 let's say
they start with Knight f6
there you go c4 and then he 6 and now
you add a huge turning point Knight f3
or not Knight f3 oops
right f3 or Knight c3 of course if you
keep in mind that we want to play the
exchange variation against the Queen's
Gambit you just need to play Knight c3
if you go Knight f3 and black turns to
the Queen's Gambit you don't have the
possibility now to exchange here and put
the night honey - it's just over in this
in this respect and this aspect so I'm a
former aperture point of you need to
play Knight c3 that's not much choice if
you want to go into those nice lines
with the exchange on um on d5
okay one question you might ask him if
you have looked at the recent candidate
matches in in in Russia a recent it was
in May I think couple of month ago um
people constantly played the Queen's
Gambit as black and white players we're
really a little bit desperate to to
prove something and now I'm telling you
okay the Queen's Gambit it's all nice
for white well and in those matches
their black chose to two different move
orders one move order which was used
mainly by kramnik was exactly this move
order and he just said okay I'll alone
if you play Knight c3 mmm I play the
nihms oh that f3 I'll play the Queen's
Gambit I play my last card system and
try to make a draw and why the white
player simply avoided the nihms oh I've
played Knight f3 so if white wants to
really press here he has to allow the
name zone in this move order just in
terms of the Queen's Gambit you can of
course play Nadia three insn't and
search for something here but for the
sake of our repertoire
it's just essential to play Knight c3
and then fight the name zone the other
move order which was employed and this
was done by I think Rio Grande and a job
of also was Bishop e7 IAM so they
allowed this kind of exchange variation
and I think there was actually one game
of y-term had a slight advantage from
but yeah this also
has got some prospects for white to play
for an advantage but it's it still it's
still very very solid of course I'm not
I'm not I don't know all the games play
there but the main point was that the
white players were avoiding the name
zone because the main moves water there
was night f6e six and ninety-five
Kramnik of course never I think really
never allowed the exchange variation
with black in this form there are
actually very few top-class players who
know this line because it's just has got
the reputation of being yeah better for
white easy to play and the statistics
are just scary at some point if black
really knows his stuff and plays really
in and then exact fashion exists its
playable but it's difficult you
experience a few study lots of games
here for instance you can just go to the
men himself garry kasparov
he played he played the exchange
variation all the time when you got the
chance to do so people rarely allowed it
because I think he's got nearly 100
percent score and there are others just
have a look at the databases or or
online and you find lots of instructive
games there with the exchange variation
okay I guess some that's it for d4 d5 I
recommend it I think a really nice book
it's it's worth buying if you're
interested in this kind of repertoire
okay thanks for watching and leave any
comments or questions on YouTube